(light instrumental music)
- [Narrator] It's taken
6,000 years for nature
to carve these remarkable formations.
The marble caves of
Chile Chico are located
on a peninsula of solid marble bordering
a remote glacial lake that spans
the Chile/Argentina border.
The lake is fed by rivers coming
from several surrounding glaciers.
As the glaciers melt and grow,
the waters slowly carve out the marble
leaving behind masterpieces
fit for a museum.
These distinct bright
blue waters are caused
by suspended particles from the glaciers
reflecting the blue part of sunlight.
Getting to this location isn't easy.
It's a long journey requiring a flight,
a 200-mile drive into the wilderness
and a boat ride just to get
there, but it's worth it.
The remarkable swirling patterns on the cave
reflect the lake's blue waters changing
with the water levels and the season.
Nature truly is the greatest artist.